on the hill today for the giants will be
the right hand of veteran anthony
scafoni discovany
in his eighth year at the big league
level six feet tall 195 pounder out of
freehold new jersey
he is 31 years of age this year he is
12-6 with a 3-2-4 era very solid season
look at the strikeouts
and a rifle shot to left that's in on
one hop in front of darren ruff
so new man at the top of the order good
result a lead off single gets things
started for the braves peterson not a
threat to steal and freeman hits a
ground ball to longoria he'll underhand
it to crawford crawford the first double
play
yeah i think crawford could play second
base
not a problem giants are coming up
and max free he's had good luck against
the giants that's what we need to happen
in game three today yeah no question
look it's a good lineup good team in
that ballpark good day game ball club
they shade him slightly toward right in
the outfield
and a little tamper right back to the
mouth that's how you take care of rough
a ground ball out
sharply ahead but a short hop handled by
ozzy and max free tom breezes through
the first inning slater dead straight
away center field
got him on the outside corner
back toward the two seamer beautiful
rosario didn't miss that he whacks that
into the right field corner as the
braves have their second hit of the game
it comes with two outs
and 17 doubles for rosario
get to crawford
crawford's got it
inside retired no damage done on the two
out double by rosario
[Applause]
you know maybe doesn't tell the whole
story you know you're not that was a
great pitch there
fastball or sinker in starts it into the
inside corner just lets it run in off
the plate now danger zone right lefty
hit left-handed hitter down and in
that's okay that pitch is down and then
crawford wants he loves it sees it eyes
lights up light up but the ball finishes
it off the plate can't do anything with
it
swaying animus
max freed with back-to-back strikeouts
sends us to inning number three where
dansby will get going back free to the
top of his game no score in game three
at oracle park
towards the hole crawford another
backhanded play the throw to first got
him
he does it again
it's every day
he'll do something as he goes to his
right deep in the hole
come up gunning and he knows he has to
hurry dansby swanson can run
back doored him and he got him
mono
leads from second with two outs
fastball popped him up
peterson drifts back almost
misplayed that but he recovers and that
will retire the side ozzy obese will
lead off for atlanta as we're in the
fourth already
solano out on the grass in right field
and he got him
got him
four strike gots two in the fourth for
the giants
they get to send up their beef it'll be
brian longoria and posey coming up
mongoria to follow
ryan
flips one into left field he's got a
base hit
well and a lead off base hit that means
a little bit more
it was refreshing a nice change in
weather but
ground ball should be two
just what the doctor ordered max freed
gives up a lead off hit longori and
posey failed to advance and the braves
go to the fifth scoreless
payoff pitch
got him
[Applause]
back door sink
absolute perfect pitch
deval gave up on this pitch halfway to
the
home plate and then watched the movement
late right back to the zone rosario with
his 17th double four-game hit streak now
and he unloads on the first pitch headed
toward triples alley at 4 15 and brian
can't get it the ball bounces high off
the bricks rosario around second on his
way to third and the braves are in
business he ambushed it
a one-out triple
so neither guy backing off
buster sets up inside
[Applause]
tap to third coming home
buster's got it out is rosario
and the contact play is go on contact
with the balls on the ground and rosario
no hesitation
put the pressure on the defense and
longoria throws a perfect strike to
posey and rosario had none where to go
on the ground to crawford crawford's
going to go the short way and they got
him
this gifani pitches through a one-out
triple
the giants mvp candidate leading off a
scoreless fifth
got him to swing and miss really good
pitch man oh man is he something
third strikeout for free
roller two ozzy in the shift freed keeps
setting him up and knocking him down
nine ground outs for max he'll take
matters into his own hands as we head to
a scoreless sixth
sinker again trying to bring that back
over the flight
peterson hits it high in here to
straight away center to the wall leaping
try and the grab made by slater and then
he dropped it
peterson stands at second there's a
break for atlanta
he had it for a moment it dropped to the
warning track and the braves have a
runner aboard with one out did it hit
the glove or was he did he trap it no he
missed it sure did this time just jump
looked like got got turned around a tiny
bit right at the very end he's stefanie
sets
throws
he struck him out swinging
sixth strikeout for decephany two down
peterson still at second and here is the
dangerous the all-star freddie freeman
swing at the ground ball to third right
to longoria the throw to first
inning over
so he got him on the first pitch it is
nothing to nothing reid starts the giant
sixth with his mound opponent declining
who sacrificed his first time up
and quick work is made of him max
freight's fourth strikeout his curveball
is really starting to bite trades a
strike away from sending us to the
seventh
strike three what a time for a curveball
ice water in his veins max freed strikes
out his fifth man
to quote another left-hander just give
me a run
we go to the seven
we are in the seventh
hit high in the air deep right field
bryant going back into triples alley
can't get that one he short-armed it
riley on his way to second he's gonna
throw out an anchor and stop there
another extra base hit for the braves
riley comes back from an o2 count duvall
is the hitter you'd love to bring in
riley here at the
least high fly ball deep left center
field did duval get it all yes he did
atlanta breaks through
adam duvall with a two-run homer
and the braves have taken
a two to nothing lead and it's the end
of the line for anthony d sclafani who
ran into trouble in the seventh
and now rosario hits a rope to right
double triple homer and into mccovey
cove he's got the easy one left for the
cycle now
so littell greeted rudely rosario
unloads with his 12th homer
on the ground right to dansby
max freed with seven masterful shutout
innings the la kid is dominating the
giants and the braves lead three nothing
you have to factor in when you face the
giants
is this one on the ground freeman goes
to second for one and the return to
first is in time double play
can't give him any unforced errors with
all this thunder in this lineup but good
pitch by luke great turn by freddy
freddy freeman hit for the cycle august
18th rosario a chance to join him here
little looper he's got it
rosario has hit for the cycle
and he wants that baseball you bet
double triple homer
single
four hits and i think he's seen five
pitchers maybe today that's awesome good
for him two outs the braves run out away
from a happy flight
strong came out
will smith with a one two three ninth
the braves shut out the giants
you